why don't we go next to colin from
oregon
colin you're on the air hi can you hear
me okay
yes i can beautifully oh thank you wow
this is really amazing i've never done
anything like this
well let's do it uh so well i'm curious
usually you do this on fridays are you
doing it on a wednesday what's going on
we always do it on wednesday for the
friday show
oh really yeah oh i thought so why
because i remember you i was watching
you said well we do this live so i was
under the impression that you shoot the
shows
the day that you post them is that not
true it's not true with the calls
because sometimes we like extra time
just in case we need to if
in case they're really bad like for
example let's say this call didn't go
anywhere we would have time to like cut
it and film
something else oh sure because i'm sure
you get some people
maybe they call them they really don't
know what to say or yeah sometimes it
happens
well it's funny because your nerves act
up because they're like okay i'm talking
with the radio person
uh this person makes a full career
talking and you're like well i
listened to your show i'm actually a
recent listener
and you're getting me into politics
beautiful
so i'm really kind of new at this um but
i do have a good question for you i hope
it's a good question good
so the reason i don't watch a lot of
conservative news well i do watch it
but i just i feel like the way they
present information
is so aggressive yes you agree i
completely
i when you said when you said i believe
the way they present information
i was thinking aggressive in my mind and
then you said it i agree and the thing
is a lot of people like that a lot of
people like the idea that
hey trump's a big man and ben shapiro
talks
quickly and stephen crowder wears a gun
bra
while he talks and so this is like
yeah it doesn't even matter what they
say it's how they're saying it i can 100
agree with you now so let's talk about
uh conservative religion now you also
talked about
um you are jewish correct
yeah yes i'm ethnically jewish and
culturally jewish i'm not religious
but so we talk about uh religious
ideology um we talk about the praise and
worship
the high and mighty the uh we give our
souls and so i find a lot of
conservative religious
uh ideas to be like well you don't need
to understand why
you just believe okay right
so maybe conservative tries to appeal to
that by being like you guys
you got uh even ted cruz was like
for us to go against the woke we need to
wake up and it's like okay
um i'm confused i'm i'm confused as well
but you are
absolutely spot on that there's this
aggressive nature
to the presentation from a lot of these
right-wingers
and uh it for for me it's just a i mean
it's like
i wouldn't be agreeing with them either
way but
um i completely find it off-putting but
it's a feature not a bug
for for many on the right all right
colin thank you i appreciate the call
that's all the time we have
today so if i didn't get to you consider
this an apology but we will take phone
calls again thanks everybody quick break
and then we'll be right back